if you're planning a last-minute trip
this weekend you are not alone
half of all hotel bookings in the United
States are made three days or less
before arrival the mobile booking app
hotel tonight helps last-minute
travelers find deals on rooms it was
launched in 2011 the app has 25,000
hotel partners in more than 35 countries
last year it earned 300 million dollars
in gross booking volume Sam shank is a
co-founder and CEO of hotel tonight
we're pleased to have him here how do
you make this work yeah so we have a
really simple pitch for our hotel
partners they say that if you guys have
empty rooms available we can put them on
hotel tonight and you can fill rooms and
generate incremental revenue and for the
hotel it's a win and for the consumer to
win - because a business but it's great
to make everybody happy
when you're building a marketplaces but
how do you guys make a profit off of
that we take a commission so if the room
sells for you know hundred dollars we'll
take a cut of that so we only get paid
if we deliver the revenue to our hotel
partner okay so we're looking at the app
so you you I put on the app I punch it
up and you're gonna show me what we're
gonna show you the very best deals for
right now for tonight for the area
around you and what we do is we sort
through about in New York would be like
400 hotels and we find the very best
deals I'm to save you time and and
really make you be able to get in that
last minute room cool you have sweets in
those category do ya I'm just just
making it inquiry for people that like
sweets so you cover all the categories
yeah I'm scroll to the bottom you'll see
what's called the high roller category
which is a which is a suite and again an
amazing discounts on those sweets so why
do you need a sweet
I just Charlie I just think literally I
just love a good hotel room and room
service that's my idea of a great time
honestly but this is very different than
the airlines because if the airlines you
wait till the last minute your prices go
way up that's right it works the exact
opposite so the worst time to book a
flight is right before you get on board
for a hotel if you are waiting longer
you're gonna find better values and
that's because the hotel's there's more
fragmentation and the hotels have this
interest in getting that last possible
dollar when we talk about last min
hotel bookings what's the ideal
timeframe we're talking about a day
before two days before a week before yep
so we started with tonight and then
we've expanded to a week ahead and so
you can book your weekend getaway a week
before that gave people a little more
flexibility but the best time to book is
really as late as you feel comfortable
waiting so for some people like my
parents when they use the app they're
booking absolutely they booked on
Wednesday for a weekend getaway that's
for them is a very last minute when I
booked I'm booking it like 10:00 p.m.
right and that's fine with me
do you know people say you were obsessed
with travel I'm curious about your back
story about this and so I grew up in
Charlottesville Virginia wonderful towns
but a small town and I didn't do a lot
of travel growing up I didn't go
overseas when I was in college and so I
got bit by the travel bug though in my
20s unfortunately I didn't have any
money then so I didn't get to travel a
ton and then I was looking to start at a
company and I wanted to combine a
personal interest with what I thought
was a great business opportunity and
travel was the network you created three
yeah we got ups so the first two were
web-based and they one was a hotel
review site called travel post and then
at travel deal search engine called deal
base and both of those I call in my
training wheels I learned a lot by doing
them and we're using our phone and then
I saw the opportunity mobile exactly and
I said mobile is gonna change everything
what's it gonna do for travel and then I
thought about booking a hotel really
late we go until 2:00 in the morning you
don't have a computer with you if you
hotel really late I said this is the the
right way to take advantage of mobile
and bring them something clearly Airbnb
is a trend in the hotel business
absolutely what else a successful - well
I think that this last minute travel is
becoming mainstream and when I started
mobile booking was only 2% 2% of all
hotel bookings now it's over half and
last minutes over half and so what was
seen as like oh this is gonna be for
emergencies is now the way people travel
so people instead of doing that like the
the week-long trip they're doing
weekend trips they say well the weather
looks good here the price activated
mayor alright that's me Shane works for
hotel tonight